hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of
Avengers stuff happening in and around
spider-man homecoming they moved to New
York now so there's a really big Ironman
Easter Egg that we just found out about
so this is gonna be breakdown so they've
been filming the super serious hardcore
spider-man film in New York City they
fill most of the movie in Atlanta but
then they went to New York City to film
a lot of exterior New York scenes stuff
that you couldn't get in a studio in
Atlanta so like Spider Man lives in
Queens a lot of the exterior shots of
his Street when he's walking around
standing in alleyways trying to put his
costume on some iconic spider-man shots
things that it just helps to have New
York City exteriors in architecture for
so one other really awesome Iron Man
Easter like we all know the Iron Man's
in the movie we learned that John
Favreau is coming back as happy don't
know how much of the movie is going to
be in but as they mostly use the two of
them for comedy you can expect it to be
pretty funny but in addition to like the
actual stuff that Iron Man is there to
do there's a really cool big action set
piece Easter Egg
so naturally big spider-man movie you
expect a bunch of big action set pieces
but what is one of the biggest pieces of
New York City architecture that is in
Queens where spider-man lives Flushing
Meadows Park smack dab in the middle of
Queens is where stark Expo is so
supposedly there's going to be a big
action set piece there and obviously a
lot of that would be CG be get certain
exterior shots for that like you get
stuff for the people to actually build
the CG on so when Jon Favreau you know
like come back to the future if you
haven't seen it in a while
Iron Man 2 was the first movie to
introduce the stark Expo idea so Jon
Favreau said that when he was a kid
living in the area like he would go
visit that so he got a brought the
spirit of the 1964 World's Fair back
when he created the stark Expo for the
Marvel Universe and when they were
making that movie six or seven years ago
he was doing interviews about how the
stark Expo would play into the future of
the Marvel Universe little did he know
that they would also be able to use it
during spider-man there was no
spider-man on the books back when they
were making Iron Man 2 but he did say
that it would be a thing in the Captain
America movie which didn't come out till
the year after Iron Man 2 so this is all
way back during Marvel phase 1 but if
you remember that first Captain America
movie
that's where we saw the hovering card
that Howard Stark was experimenting on
like he was experimenting with repulsor
technology we saw the original human
torch's uniform Bucky and Steve were
just like walking around just taking it
all in
so the stark Expo is just a touchstone
for a number of big characters in
actually spider-man living in Queens
would probably go visit that place every
once in a while but as for shenanigans
remains to be seen how much fun Iron Man
and spider-man get to have there with
whatever big villain fight they have so
like when we saw Iron Man
during Iron Man 2 he was still really
high on himself that you know the whole
through line for that movie was is that
being Iron Man was poisoning him he
needed to recenter himself so to speak
as he created the new energy source but
you can understand how spider-man is
gonna be like this wisecracking teenager
gonna be making a lot of the same
mistakes that Iron Man made before he
completed the first couple arcs on his
hero's journey I'm just expecting a
sequence like the opening of Iron Man 2
maybe not so much ac/dc though that kind
of music feels a little specific to Tony
Stark's character I feel you know like
Spider Man is gonna have his own
soundtrack it'll be completely unique
from the other Marvel movies so whatever
his like super or cocky web slinging
montages before he gets his ass handed
to him it'll be a little bit different
but like we've been talking about stark
Expo important for Iron Man's character
important for spider-man's character
what about Captain America there's
rumors that he's also going to be in the
film like what's the big lesson is he
gonna show up in Queens is spider-man
gonna go visit his friend in Brooklyn I
feel like they wouldn't have mentioned
him so much in that post-credit scene if
they hadn't intended to follow up with
another Captain America tag in the
spider-man movie in some way it would be
really awesome if he did go to Brooklyn
in Captain America just pointed out all
the different places that he got beat up
got beat up over there got beat up by a
guy in that alley got stuffed into a
trash can over there so like the Captain
America spider-man lesson is you get
knocked down you keep getting back up I
could do this all day it would be
awesome if they gave that line to
spider-man in the movie that's usually
the easiest way to invoke really
important moments from the past and
bring them forward like when he's
fighting Ironman at the end of Civil War
I could do this all day but let me know
in the comments what do you think
they're gonna do with stark Expo in
Spiderman home
now that's really only like a small part
of Iron Man in the movie like he's not
just gonna show up at stark Expo they'll
probably be something else going on with
them
but it's just such a big location and it
would be stupid for them not to include
it but the Russos actually did clarify a
little bit about Iron Man Captain
America pre Avengers infinity war they
did say like you know no matter what
happened at the end of Civil War there's
still a little bit of hurt feelings so
they're not gonna be buddy-buddy even if
they do appear in the same movie so I'm
not really expecting them to meet up
before infinity war so if Captain
America does show up during Spider Man
homecoming it'll probably be in some
completely separate scene that has
nothing to do with what Iron Man's doing
in the movie but just cannot wait to see
happy driving Ironman around again like
the two of them they work so well
together when they're on screen but
because most of the movies that Jon
Favreau was in he was directing like
there just wasn't that much he could do
Iron Man 3 was the first movie that he
was in as the happy character that he
was not also directing now he also
executive produces the Marvel movies but
really it's just kind of like creative
oversight like he's not on set every
single day just like telling them what
to do he just signed on to do another
Disney live-action adaptation so if he
does come back to do another Iron Man
movie it's still a couple years away so
again I and there is a rumor that there
will be spider-man footage dropping in
the next couple of weeks there is a
guardians of the galaxy 2 trailer that's
dropping around Christmas around dr.
strange Star Wars rogue one time so I'm
not expecting them to drop Spider Man
and guardians footage at the exact same
time they'll probably want to space that
out a little bit because they're too
super huge things that everybody really
wants to see so they probably want you
to focus on like one big thing at a time
so if we don't see spider-man footage
before we get that first Guardians
trailer we probably won't see spider-man
footage till the very end of the year or
even til the Superbowl but get hype and
if you guys haven't been watching it
Luke Cage is awesome I'll be posting the
rest of my videos over the course of
next week
so speaking of trailers they also said
that there's a new Iron Fist trailer
that's supposed to drop at New York
Comic Con next week but no confirmation
on that yet of course I'll totally do a
video if it does drop so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and if
there's any other Marvel movie videos
you guys want me to do just let me know
in the comments what are you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
all
all my spider-man homecoming videos and
you can click here for new flash season
3 footage thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you